I guess we got to do it again oh
um yeah you ready I want to thank my
daughter for telling me just before I
got up here if you don't win dad you're
still good Sidney Poitier said I saw you
once
and I looked in your eyes and there was
a connection
and he says I give to you responsibility
so I'm taking that responsibility
tonight my grandmother's name is Estelle
Marie Talley
and she's not here tonight
and this is gonna be the toughest part
but she was my first acting teacher she
told me stand up straight put your
shoulders back act like you've got some
sense and then when I would act a fool
and she could get an Oscar for the way
she whooped me because she was great at
it and after she whipped me he said I
want you to be a southern gentleman
and uh she still talks to me now
only now she talks to me in my dreams
and I can't wait to go to sleep tonight
because we got a lot to talk about I
love you